at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking question magnetic organism
living tissue over metal endoskeleton
this episode is brought to you by
headspace more than 80% of the people I
have interviewed world-class performers
across the military entertainment sports
and beyond all have some type of
meditative practice I tried for years
and years and failed miserably the key
is making it simple and you can
dramatically improve your life in just
10 minutes a day and technology can help
you this change comes through guided
meditation and headspace is by far the
most popular app for this purpose more
than four million users it's meditation
made simple so what I recommend is that
you take this practice meditation which
is rooted in thousands of years of
tradition supported by thousands of
scientific studies and try it for 10
minutes a day for 10 days that's all you
need to do you could also check out the
founder Andy Pettit combs TED talk which
has more than 5.5 million views his last
name is PUD di c om b e if you want to
look that up but otherwise download the
free headspace app I have it on my phone
and begin there take ten program for ten
days of guided meditation completely
free ten minutes a day that's all it
takes you should give it a shot
headspace calm forward-slash Tim just go
to headspace calm forward-slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it investing service
led by technologists from places like
Apple and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront dot-com forward
slash tim take the risk assessment quiz
which only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than 10 asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront comm
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on this
show is because I use them and recommend
them in this case it's a little
different I don't use wealthfront yet
because I'm not allowed to here's the
deal they wanted to sponsor this podcast
but because of SEC regulations companies
that invest your money are not allowed
to use client testimonials so I couldn't
be a user and have them on the podcast
but I've been so impressed by wealth
front that I've invested a significant
of my own money at least for me in the
team and the company itself so I am an
investor and hope to soon use it as a
client now back to the recommendation as
a Tim Ferriss show listener you'll get
$15,000 managed for free if you decide
to open an account but just start with
seeing the portfolio that they would
suggest for you take two minutes fill
out their questionnaire at wealthfront
comm forward slash Tim it's fast it's
free there's no downside that I can
think of now I do have to read a
mandatory disclaimer wealthfront Inc is
an SEC registered investment advisor
investing in securities involves risks
and there is the possibility of losing
money past performance is no guarantee
of future results please visit wealth
front comm to read their full disclosure
so check it out guys this is one of the
hottest most innovative companies coming
out of Silicon Valley and they're
killing it they've become massively
popular just take a look see what
portfolio they would create for you and
you can use that information however you
want wealthfront comm forward slash tim
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show it is usually my job to
deconstruct world-class performers of
some type whether they are from sports
military chess entertainment god knows
where they come from everywhere and you
find a lot of commonalities across them
this episode though is a special episode
I'm going to hand the mic over to Seneca
the younger and what you were going to
hear is roughly 2,000 years old and it
teaches you how to deconstruct or
construct a world class life and suffice
to say Seneca and his letters had an
enormous impact on my life I revisit his
writing many dozens of times per year
and this particular letter has affected
me in myriad of ways letter 18 on the
festivals and fasting and I want you to
pay particular attention to a few
passages that begin around 2 minutes and
20 seconds in with the line set aside a
certain number of days and what this
will teach you and the Lucid 8 is how to
practice poverty and reduce fear
specifically you can think of it as
inoculating yourself against fear by
practicing the worst case scenarios this
is an incredibly powerful concept that
you can rehearse the things that you
fear to take the fear away from them and
out of yourself
it is extremely practical and I do this
with short-term fasting which of course
you shouldn't do with that medical
supervision I must say that I'm not a
doctor don't play one on the internet I
do that with wearing the same clothing
for instance like white t-shirt and
jeans for a week or so or you could do
it by eating very cheap food rice and
beans for instance two to three dollars
a day in total cost for a week but I
will let Seneca get into it because he
will do a much better job than I could
ever dare to attempt I am for you to
listen to more of these letters the 27
hours or so of audio that I just put out
is in the Tao of Seneca this is not a
big moneymaker for me it's something
I've wanted to do for decades just to
make these letters available to you guys
in audio format so you can do it say on
the way to coffee or on the way to work
once per day in the morning you can
digest one of these letters and they can
set you up for optimal performance in
high-stress situations so you don't
overly react and hurt yourself and
others so you can check out the town of
Seneca at audible.com for word slash
Tim's books check it out you can listen
to samples and for those of you who
downloaded it a few days ago there was
an issue with the longer on the
shortness of life essay so you can skip
that we're going to be removing it but
all the other letters should be in fine
form and this is one of my favorites
like I said letter 18 on festivals and
fasting pay attention it's changed my
life I think he can do the same for you
and if you want additional resources I
will try to include them in the show
notes so for our work week comm forward
slash podcast and check out the Tao
Seneca at audible.com for word slash
Tim's books enjoy
letter 18 on festivals and fasting it is
the month of December and yet the city
is at this very moment in a sweat
license is given to the general
merrymaking everything resounds with
mighty preparations as if a Saturnalia
differed at all from the usual business
day so true it is that the difference is
nil that I regard is correct at the
remark of the man who said once December
was a month now it is a year if I had
you with me I should be glad to consult
you and find out what you think should
be done whether we ought to make no
change in our daily routine or whether
in order not to be out of sympathy with
the ways of the public we should dine in
Gare fashion and doff the toga as it is
now we Romans have changed our dress for
the sake of pleasure and holiday making
though in former times that was only
customary when the state was disturbed
and had fallen on evil days I am sure
that if I know you were right playing
the part of an umpire you would have
wished that we should be neither like
the Liberty capped throng in always nor
in always unlike them unless perhaps
this is just the season when we ought to
lay down the law to the soul and bid it
be alone in refraining from pleasures
just when the whole mob has led itself
go in pleasures for this is the surest
proof which a man can get of his own
constancy if he neither seeks to things
which are seductive and Elohim to luxury
nor is led into them it shows much more
courage to remain dry and sober when the
mob is drunk and vomiting but it shows
greater self-control to refuse to
withdraw oneself and to do what the
crowd does but in a different way thus
neither making oneself conspicuous nor
becoming one of the crowd for one may
keep holiday without extravagance
I am so firmly determined however to
test the constancy of your mind that
drawing from the teachings of great men
I shall give you also a lesson set aside
a certain number of days during which
you shall be content with a scanty ax
stand cheapest fair with coarse and
rough dress saying to yourself the while
is this the condition that I feared it
is precisely in times of immunity from
care that the soul should toughen itself
beforehand for occasions of greater
stress and it is while fortune is kind
that it should fortify itself against
her violence in days of peace the
soldier performs maneuvers throws up
earthworks with no enemy in sight and
we're ease himself by crow to attest
toil in order that he may be equal to
unavoidable toil if you would not have a
man flinch when the crisis comes train
him before it comes such as the course
which those men have followed who in
their imitation of poverty have every
month come almost to want that they
might never recoil from what they had so
often rehearsed you need not suppose
that I mean meals like to moans or
poppers Hut's or any other device which
luxurious millionaire is used to beguile
the tedium of their lives
let the palate be a real one and the
coarse cloak let the bread it be hard
and grimy endure all this for three or
four days at a time sometimes for more
that it may be a test of yourself
instead of a mere hobby then I assure
you my dear Luke Ilyas you will leap for
joy when filled with a penny worth of
food and you will understand that a
man's peace of mind does not depend upon
fortune for even when angry she grants
enough for our needs
there is no reason however why you
should think that you were doing
anything great
for you will merely be doing what many
thousands of slaves and many thousands
of poor men are doing every day but you
may credit yourself with this item that
you will not be doing it under
compulsion and that it will be as easy
for you to endure it permanently as to
make the experiment from time to time
let us practice our strokes on the dummy
let us become intimate with poverty so
that fortune may not catch us off our
guard we shall be rich with all the more
comfort if we once learn how far poverty
is from being a burden even Epicurus the
teacher of pleasure used to observe
stated intervals during which he
satisfied his hunger in niggardly
fashion he wished to see whether he
thereby fell short of full and complete
happiness and if so by what amount he
fell short and whether this amount was
worth purchasing at the price of great
effort at any rate he makes such a
statement in the well-known letter
written to paly honest in the archon
ship of kirino's indeed he boasts that
he himself lived on less than a penny
but that metrodorus whose progress was
not yet so great needed a whole penny do
you think that there can be fullness on
such fare yes and there is pleasure also
not that shifty and fleeting pleasure
which needs a Philip now and then but a
pleasure that is steadfast and sure for
though water barley meal and crusts of
barley bread are not a cheerful diet yet
it is the highest kind of pleasure to be
able to derive pleasure from this sort
of food and to have reduced one's needs
to that modicum which no unfairness of
fortune can snatch away even prison fare
is more generous and those who have been
set apart for capital punishment are not
so meanly fed by the man who is to
execute them
therefore what a noble soul must one
have to descend of one's own free will
to a diet which even those who have been
sentenced to death have not to fear
this is indeed for stalling the spear
thrusts of fortune so began my dear
looky-loos to follow the custom of these
men and set apart certain days on which
you shall withdraw from your business
and make yourself at home with the scant
iasts fare establish business relations
with poverty dare or my friend to score
in the sight of wealth and mould thyself
to kinship with thy God for he alone is
in kinship with God who has scorned
wealth of course I do not forbid you to
possess it but I would have you reach
the point at which you possess it
dauntlessly
this can be accomplished only by
persuading yourself that you can live
happily without it as well as with it
and by regarding riches always as likely
to elude you but now I must begin to
fold up my letter settle your debts
first you cry here is a draft on a
procuress he will pay down the sum
uncover and anger baguettes madness you
cannot help knowing the truth of these
words since you have had not only slaves
but also enemies but indeed this emotion
blazes out against all sorts of persons
it Springs from love as much as from
hate and shows itself not less in
serious matters than ingest and sport
and it makes no difference how important
the provocation may be but into what
kind of soul it penetrates similarly
with fire it does not matter how great
is the flame but what it falls upon for
solid timbers have repelled a very great
fire conversely dry and easily in
flammable stuff nourishes the slightest
spark into a conflagration so it is with
anger my dear Luke will use the outcome
of a mighty anger is madness and hence
anger should be avoided not merely that
we may escape excess but that we may
have a healthy mind
so well hey guys this is Tim again just
a few more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet Friday do
you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and 500 Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it investing service
led by technologists from places like
Apple and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealthfront is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first fifteen thousand which is
managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront com forward slash Tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest a thirty thousand dollar account
for instance now normally when I have a
sponsor on this show is because I use
them and recommend them in this case
it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealth front that I've invested
a significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get $15,000 managed for
free if you decide to open a account but
just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront comm forward slash Tim it's
fast it's free there's no downside that
I can think of now I do have to read a
mandatory disclaimer wealthfront
Inc is an SEC registered investment
advisor investing in securities involves
risks and there is the possibility of
losing money past performance is no
guarantee of future results please visit
wealth front comm to read their full
disclosure so check it out guys this is
one of the hottest most innovative
companies coming out of Silicon Valley
and they're killing it they've become
massively popular just take a look see
what portfolio they would create for you
and you can use that information however
you want wealthfront comm forward slash
tip
this episode is brought to you by
headspace more than 80% of the people I
have interviewed world-class performers
across the military entertainment sports
and beyond all have some type of
meditative practice I tried for years
and years and failed miserably the key
is making it simple and you can
dramatically improve your life in just
10 minutes a day and technology can help
you this change comes through guided
meditation and headspace is by far the
most popular app for this purpose more
than four million users it's meditation
made simple so what I recommend is that
you take this practice meditation which
is rooted in thousands of years of
tradition supported by thousands of
scientific studies and try it for 10
minutes a day for 10 days that's all you
need to do you could also check out the
founder and II put it Combs TED talk
which has more than 5.5 million views
his last name is PewDiePie CEO mve if
you want to look that up but otherwise
download the free headspace app I have
it on my phone and begin there take ten
program for ten days of guided
meditation completely free 10 minutes a
day that's all it takes
you should give it a shot headspace calm
forward / Tim just go to headspace calm
forward / Tim and until next time thank
you for listening
you